do you outline every story that you
write yeah I'm yeah I'm pretty thorough
with my outlining I tend to I'll spend
quite a bit of time outlining before I
even write the full like I usually have
a complete full outline and then jump
into the story so I'll have a really
specific idea of the objective of every
single scene and ultimately it saves me
time when I first started writing I was
anti outline I kind of had the attitude
you know it's the young attitude of just
like you know I'm just gonna write and
my my guts gonna tell me what's right
and what it's meaningful and stuff like
that and that works for a lot of writers
but I noticed that I would hit a lot of
dead ends and I became emotionally
attached to those dead ends and then it
became really hard to rewrite until I
just drove my stories off the cliff and
so little by little the more I you know
honestly that Ron Media 24-point thing
was huge because it was so simple you
could literally sit there and just plot
out a story in an hour and you'd have a
really good idea of where was going and
then from there you're you know that's
to me that's when you go from like you
know discovering your story to actually
becoming craftsman or a class person or
you're working on the story and taking
control of it and then you start just to
take a step back and then you know it's
almost like a render machine you're
rendering your story before you ever sit
down and write it so then the script
really just becomes kind of a secondary
artifact of all the work that you've put
into it so yeah I spend a lot of time
outlining it's and it's you know a lot
of people feel like it takes away from
the creative process usually that's kind
of the writer saying well I want to be
in the audience too and I want to
experience and be surprised by it but
outline who doesn't take away from that
because what happens when you sit down
like you've outlined you've got your
outline right here and then when you're
writing you put yourself in the moment
you're you're in the skin of the writer
or of the character and you you're
experiencing it and then if your gut
tells you to try something different try
something different see where it goes so
you're still you know the whole
Gardner versus architect the pantser
versus plot or kind of thing I call it
what is it the the assassin versus the
Berserker basically the idea that like
the the planner versus the person that
just sees what happens next and I think
it's important to to understand the
consequences of the choices you're
making but the whole process of writing
is an experiment art is an experiment
and the out the only thing that rules it
is do we make it emotionally resonant
for somebody else and as artists we get
to decide how much that is like how how
we build that relationship if we want to
do it is a little like for a living then
we become responsible to those people
that are investing in us and that's
that's when you want to be able to to
have control of your craft that's when
you want to be able to you know climb
the mountain know how you're gonna get
up there because you gotta meet a
deadline you know it's there aren't a
lot of producers that are gonna be like
alright you know we needed this three
months ago and you're still just kind of
wandering the weeds but a lot of the
process of writing is experimenting in
the weeds going into the weeds and then
stepping back and the trick is just not
not panicking when you're in the weeds
and saying okay this is part of the
process let's step back and look at the
let's look at the outline and see if
this is gonna work so for me it feels
like it's like like a map you're zooming
in and you know you can do the the
street view where you're in the
character and you're just driving along
and you're like yeah I feel this I'm
going through this Street and that's
when you're writing but then you pull
back you zoom out and you see the
overview of where you're going and
that's the outline so do you think with
without an outline a writer backs
themselves into a corner a little bit I
mean we're all vulnerable to that even
with an outline where were vulnerable to
it but again I don't believe in any
right or wrong like there's this one
writer Bob sines
he's amazing he says he doesn't outline
he's successful writes great stuff he
just wrote extra-curricular and it
fantastic I read the script it's so good
and he he does an outline but he knows
how to write he gets he gets where he
needs to go and he knows how to tell a
story so it's like it's right what works
for you is fine the important thing is
to be able to to sell it to the
producers to engage the people that it
that that need to be engaged you're
writing for readers largely so you want
to learn to the language of what they
expect but within that you know it's
it's whatever gets you there I don't
think you have any obligation but
generally speaking the average person
would benefit from taking the time to
plan out where their story's gonna go
have a good idea of how it's going to
end and then you know work toward that
in the past have you introduced that
twenty four point system to some of your
students and yes surprised yeah actually
my first in my first video I introduced
the 20 for plot points and then I break
it down into acts and the sequences and
then scenes and everything like that so
it's um it's just a really simple simple
kind of like a lot of people will stare
at the blank page I've never understood
the staring at the blank page because by
the time I'm ready to write a scene I've
already had like pages of writing I
can't it's like the slingshot you're
just like slowly like preparing like
getting all the scenes getting the
character getting the plot the conflict
you know what every character wants so
when you sit down you're ready to write
you let go and you're just flying you
know but it's but it really comes down
to everybody discovering their own
process you know and I'm not a purist
like lots of people don't outline and
they're very good writers are very
successful in a lot of that's the
intuition or their experience that
informs it
you